hey I've got something really
interesting for you here a Jeanine Pirro
who is a former judge I'm shocked she
actually was a judge at one point and
it's an incredible indictment on the
American justice system she's now a fox
news host she went on c-span and it did
not go well at all she has been one of
the persistent outrageous the opposite
of an ever Trumper and always Trumper an
unhinged defender of Donald Trump on Fox
News just persistently all the time any
crazy notion from Donald Trump she will
defend she went on a c-span program
called Washington journal people call in
to that show and she was straight up
confronted by a caller this is a caller
from Texas who reamed her out so
severely in such a way that she was
visibly uncle' unsure what to do she
either could not respond or chose not to
respond
she looks visibly stunned by this
dressing down that a caller gave her
take a look at this our president and
our beautiful first lady they went down
to El Paso Texas and they posed with a
baby that the president's rhetoric Fox
News writer your rhetoric had helped to
orphan and I think this this thing about
Trump is making America great again
Trump has made America hate again and
it's this hatred of races I hear it all
the time when I see talk to Republicans
and they say oh I went down to Texas and
there are all these Mexicans down there
and they're all speaking Spanish well I
Got News for you those weren't Mexicans
those were the Americans that guy that
went down to El Paso to shoot a bunch of
Mexicans he shot a bunch of Americans
and I'm really tired of this
anti-immigrant anti people with
brown-skinned rhetoric that's coming out
of out of fox news coming out of people
like you and coming out of our president
it's demeaning it's beneath the office
it's beneath you
used to be a judge you know better it's
time that that stopped and thank you
Carolyn will get a response look you
know what I refuse to accept your
recitation of the facts you are dead
wrong the problem in this country the
color of anyone and don't you dare
accuse me of any kind of issue related
to color I have 30 years of prosecuting
without fear or favor and making sure
that hate crimes were vigorously
prosecuted I fought for I fought for a
hate crimes law it's genuinely shocking
that she didn't interrupt and the look
on her face of growing confusion and
this almost inability to jump in is
really prices if you if you're just
listening you should definitely watch
the clip beautiful to see now not
everything the guy said was a hundred
percent true but he did pretty
accurately get into this idea of
stochastic terrorism that I've been
talking about for a long time and the
impact of what Jeanine Pirro and other
Fox Trump flunkies do and the effect
that it has on the real world she has
made commentaries on Fox News that have
suggested that Democrats entice
undocumented Hispanic immigrants to come
to the United States so that they can
vote for Democrats this is something
that had a prominent role in the El Paso
shooters manifesto the idea of I need to
go take out Hispanic people because
Democrats are in bed with them and
bringing them to the US to try to turn
elections in their favor I don't know
what's crazier that she was a judge
which is nuts I mean it is it is insane
that this is someone who was actually a
judge or that she continues to be a fox
news host despite participating in this
sort of blind erratic reflexive loyalty
to the President and even kind of
becoming an aggravating factor in many
of the problems that the president is
creating himself there are actually lots
of really crazy right-wing judges we
think of judges as these sort of beyond
partisanship arbiters
of the law in some way and you have to
look only at the fact that Jeanine Pirro
was a judge that crazy Texas congressman
Louie Gohmert was a judge if I recall
correctly and this gets to the bigger
problem of judges there are so many
right-wingers who talk about they want
textual conservative justices what they
are actually talking about are complete
and total partisan hacks who do the
opposite of simply be conservative if
conservative means merely applying the
letter of the law to the circumstances
if they do that if it helps Republicans
and big corporations or whoever they
want to help and if it doesn't they take
a completely different not conservative
but simply activist right-wing
perspective as judges for context here's
another caller
during Jeanine Pirro z-- appearance who
is a complete and total right-wing
lunatic saying I'm not racist but we
white people legally obtained our guns
drawing a contrast I guess to non-white
people and then saying that Jeanine
Pirro is a genius and that Donald Trump
would be really well a would be really
smart to listen to her and also slam
c-span itself during the opening this is
just another caller
during Jeanine Pirro --za pearance hi
judge I know you thought you'd get a
fair shot here on Washington journal
c-span but as you see you get six to
seven Democrat callers to one Republican
that's that they're just as bad as CNN
with the fake knows about Donald Trump
they attacking just as much as anybody
but so 3ky you can sister cuz you
probably won't be invited back well I
mean let me jump in that's not true
we're taking calls from Democrats
Republicans and independents we welcome
here her for the hour and judge Jeanine
you are welcome back anytime we'd love
to have you but caller go ahead thank
you so much I'm judging being a
prosecutor I feel that the Democrats are
attacking only white people's guns and I
not being racist but what I'm saying is
we've legally obtained our guns we go to
I are firearms we fill out background
checks and the thing that upsets me the
most and I do hope that Donald Trump
listens to you because I know you are a
very smart woman and we need people like
you talking to Donald Trump but I feared
that he doesn't see what's going on you
can find the rest of that call online
where they go into the normal black on
black crime talking points and all of
the stuff you would expect really scary
what's going on
why Jeanine Pirro is even on c-span is
beyond me that seems to be the real
problem selling her hack book but at
least one call are really backing her
off and she was visibly unclear about
how to respond let me know if you saw
this entire appearance it was wacky and
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show we will take a quick break and be
back right after this hey really quick I
want to tell you about one of our
partners VIN chera watches giving our
audience 15% off everything they offer
these guys are awesome they craft really
stylish top-quality watches for both men
and women but they sell them at a fair
price unlike a lot of their competitors
VIN chero assembles their watches in
small batches which enables them to
meticulously ensure the quality of every
watch I personally wear of inch arrow
watch I don't like the idea of spending
thousands of dollars on a watch when I
can get a really excellent watch for a
hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
that's what I think is great about
Ventura you get a watch made from
top-notch materials they look like
watches that you'd spend a ton of money
on and they're built like high-end
watches designed mechanically with
longevity in mind but you don't have to
spend an arm and a leg their entire goal
is to make watches of superior quality
available to the average person I just
got a new one called the Kairos I got
the white and silver version it looks
great I've gotten a ton of compliments
they have a huge variety of style so it
was easy to find one that fits my tastes
there are a bunch of other companies out
there selling watches at similar prices
but a lot of them look very cookie
cutter and just don't offer the same
level of craftsmanship as what you get
from bin chair oh you're not going to
find a better maid
at this grade of a price they've got a
watch for any type of look you're trying
to go for formal more casual the straps
and colors are interchangeable so you
can customize your watch to your own
preference and you can get 15% off
everything in their store when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch and use the
code Pakman at checkout